rather than crying about the fact that
so many men desire to come home from
work to a happy and grateful family you
might take a moment to consider why they
desire it why we desire it now it could
be that we're all a bunch of
woman-hating psychopaths who hate women
so much that we married and literally
dedicated Our Lives to them or
it could be that we are human beings who
feel that deepest of human longings to
love and be loved we want to love our
families by providing for them we want
to love them by being useful to them by
giving them something that they need
this is why getting laid off or fired or
forced out of work for long stretches or
even retiring can sometimes be literally
deadly for a man he feels deprived of
the opportunity to be useful to love his
family in an active and productive way
this is what lies at the root of that
terrible evil patriarchal male urge to
be a breadwinner what lies at the root
is his desire to give to those he loves